this album you're about to release is
your first album as an independent
artist right which is a big deal yeah
um this is a new space for you uh to be
who you are with already with a five
times platinum record and now you're
able to kind of move freely you're able
to kind of call the shots do what you
want to do how does it feel like like is
is it some
there's got to be like a cool
Just Energy to that yeah yeah yeah I
feel free I don't know why I keep saying
that but that's what it feels like you
feel like a a waiter's off my shoulder
you know I get to see certain things you
know what I'm saying I get to move how I
want to I mean
it's just a better positive energy all
the way around you know what I'm saying
that's how I feel you know so I'm
excited for it I was gonna say what
would you say is your was your biggest
um for people who think you just
disappeared what would you attribute
that to the reason of that is it the is
it the label thing or is it just
like what was it what was what's the
reason why we haven't gotten a lot of
music from you in the last few years
yeah it's a label thing yeah it was a
label thing bro for sure is it hard to
still stay motivated if you feel like
you're kind of like
um no
um
I'm still living yeah you know my two
feet still move you know what I'm saying
so I mean I'm grateful for that yeah and
I can work and I can grind I can do what
I want to do still so I love it man I
ain't tripping I always stay motivated
uh your writing process are you the type
of artist because when I hear your [__]
I feel like you lay the melody first and
then you go in and filling the lyrics is
that what you do yeah no pen nope
straight like
I love it my homies be laughing at me
because they'd be like what are you
doing in there he's just mumbling and
I'll be like I'm just humming you know
trying to catch the vibe yeah yeah they
come back five minutes later it's a
whole song they're like oh man that's
crazy it's that quick five minutes
you're you're a beast yeah yeah I'll be
going crazy I mean you just told me you
have like 200 unreleased songs so yeah I
got a lot of release music I'm assuming
that there's gonna be a whole lot of
pressure coming from you
[Music]
do you um look five years is a long time
uh from having a record that kind of
puts you on the Forefront of hip-hop for
a while right right
um do you feel like
you have to get any of those like
because fans have a short attention span
extent I mean nowadays man I feel like
fans are extremely
finicky they're very fair weather fans
like they'll be [__] with you one day
until the next [__] comes out and right
and then that might be better or
whatever it is right for you you kind of
feel like you're a new artist all over
again like you got to kind of remind
people who you are and what you and what
you're doing and like you know
um I feel like that yeah
um but every day I get reminded why it's
not that still you know what I'm saying
when I walk into a room everybody know
what it is already yeah so
it's like somewhere in between you know
what I'm saying it's just uh a restart
for me but to be a fresh artist nah they
know what it is already 100
um